this is a movie that where people had
actually sing to each other in a
dramatic context where you had to
believe and not be taken out of the
movie when they started to connect to
each other and saw and obviously the
most famous version is when Jennifer
Hudson sings that I'm telling you so it
was bringing the audience along slowly
to get used to that convention that was
that was the thing that I found almost
too much we were shooting the Dreamgirls
number and in the tight white dresses
that we couldn't sit down in because
they were so tight we literally would
lean back on stools between takes and we
got I don't know almost towards the end
of filming that number and we're
twirling around the circle Beyonce's
swirling we're twirling around her and
the wire got caught on my foot and I
kept feeling something tugging me and I
couldn't go i figure out what it was and
I just slowly slowly slowly went down
until I had followed all the way to the
ground which the extras got a phenomenal
kick out of the casting of this movie
was the most exciting part but in every
in every way actually from from from
Jamie Foxx to Beyonce to Jennifer to
Anika to Eddie literally every every
time we had any sort of talk about the
casting of this movie and we got our
first choices all the way around which
is rare it was thrilling to work with
henry krieger who'd written the original
score he wrote four new songs
here's a new song love you I do that
Jennifer sings to jamie cox I i think is
a great great song it was wonderful to
see the 25 years later he was still the
talents game Anika came in she killed
her audition there was no question we
wanted her to play larell however we had
a very tall Jennifer Hudson and Beyonce
with her and that was a big big question
how could these three women become the
dreams so now I hand it over to the
person who solved the problem Sharon
Davis our costume designer and he said
it so innocently well hi Anika I'm
Sharon you're gonna have to wear
six-inch heels and each dance number